getting high-quality data is paramount
for good machine learning outcomes but
public datasets aren't always suitable
for custom use cases so how can you get
your data labeled efficiently without
spending days in front of the computer
stay tuned to find out
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're gonna take a
look at the cloud AI platform data
labeling service and see how it can help
you create labeled data sets that you
can use to train machine learning models
while you should always try to collect
data in such a way that the labels are
known at the time of collection that
isn't always possible especially in the
case of say crowd-sourced data or
unstructured data like images and video
or text labeling your data after
collecting it might be necessary the
data labeling service lets you work with
human laborers to create labels for data
that you can then use to train machine
learning models let's learn a little bit
more about how this system works say
you've collected a representative data
set that you want to classify or analyze
and you're ready to try out creating a
data labeling task what does it take
let's dive in the data labeling service
has three core resources that it uses to
define a labeling task data sets label
sets and instructions you'll need all
three in order to create a labeling task
for your data now let's look at each of
these in turn the data set resource is
of course your data set it's represented
as a CSV file on Google Cloud storage
each row of the CSV file points to an
individual element of data for instance
if you have a bunch of images each row
is a GCS path to an image file for text
data each row should be a path to a text
file in addition to the CSV file you'll
also need to give the data set a name
and select the data type images video or
text once you've created your data set
you'll need to
your label set a label set is the set of
labels you want your human labelers to
use to label your images each label set
can contain up to 100 labels you can mix
and match data sets with different label
sets depending on what model you're
trying to train or you might even use
the same label set for several different
data sets try to avoid using labels
whose meanings might overlap as this can
confuse labelers it is also worth noting
that you can have a label called neither
and both which might be useful
especially in say classification
scenario once you have a data set and
corresponding label set created it's
time to create some instructions for
your labelers here are some tips for
making great instructions first up
remember that labelers don't have your
domain knowledge so make sure your
instructions are easy enough to
understand secondly be sure to include a
list of all of your possible labels with
a description of each label and third in
your instructions include examples for
every single label making sure to give
at least three positive examples and at
least one negative example covering
different kinds of cases fourth clarify
as many edge cases as you can for
example with say bounding boxes and
images be sure to state whether a
partially covered item should be
included and how tightly that bounding
box needs to be drawing the system
requires that you submit PDF
instructions so be sure to have some way
to output to PDF there's lots of ways to
do this one option that I would
recommend is to just write it up in
Google slides or Google Docs and save as
PDF now that we've created a data set
label set and instructions we're ready
to bring them all together to create a
labeling task the data labeling service
supports many different types of
labeling tasks for image data you can do
six different types of labeling there is
classification bounding boxes oriented
bounding box bounding polygon polyline
tasks or segmentation tasks for video
data the data labeling service support
classification object detection object
tracking and events now finally for text
labeling the service supports
classification classification with
sentiment and finally entity extraction
I want to close this video with some
tips for success and common questions
about the data labeling service there's
always a concern about how to ensure
high labeling quality one way to ensure
the best labeling quality possible is to
request multiple human labelers to
annotate each piece of your data in
cases where there is disagreement on
labeling additional opinions from the
other labels are gathered until there's
a consensus or the maximum number of
labelers have been reached let's take a
look at an example say we chose to have
three labelers for image classification
tasks all three labelers will classify
each image and the majority vote will
decide the final answer for image
bounding box tasks the first labeler
will draw the box and the second layer
then can verify them if the second
labeler disagrees and makes edits
continue on to the third one to get kind
of a majority opinion another potential
area of questions is around who will
label my data all data sets are labeled
by officially on-boarded subprocessors
and you can find out more information in
all the details at the GCP data
processing and security terms anytime
you're transmitting data the security
and protection of that data is paramount
it's worth noting that all data stored
in google cloud is already encrypted by
default both in transit and at rest
human labelers can only view your data
during labeling the data labeling
service is also HIPAA compliant so for
those of you working with sensitive
healthcare data
rest assured that it will be handled in
a proper manner one final tip ramp up
your data labeling jobs incrementally
start your first labeling job with a
small amount of data then see whether
the results are what you expect
you can then revise your instructions
and then create subsequent jobs and
iterate until you feel comfortable
sending larger and larger quantities of
data to be labeled this will help you
get high quality results and make the
best use of your budget both in terms of
time and money I hope this was a useful
overview of the data labeling service
and how you can get going with it and
even if you don't need to use a data
labeling service these tenants of label
creation and instructions are important
for creating accurate data sets for your
machine learning training as always I've
linked a number of useful resources down
in the description below thanks for
watching this episode of cloudy eye
adventures and if you enjoyed it click
that like button and be sure to
subscribe to get all the latest episodes
right when they come out for now check
out the data labeling service and create
your first labeling task today I look
forward to seeing you next time on AI
adventures
[Music]
[Music]